hey everyone hope you're having a great
start to your weekend i figured we'd go
over a quick review of what happened in
the bitcoin market this past week first
if we take a look the week right after
the bitcoin conference sitting at forty
thousand four hundred and thirty four
dollars give or take not exactly the big
bitcoin boom that everyone thought would
happen post conference if we then go
ahead and we take a look you can see
that the market cap is sitting right
above 750 billion dollars the inflation
rate is still about 1.77
and 90 of the bitcoin supply has already
been issued into the market there's over
1 million active addresses in the last
24 hours and miners were paid 37 million
dollars in the same time period to go
ahead and secure bitcoin the most
decentralized secure computing network
in the world bitcoin is down about 41
from its all-time high but it is up 22
from its cycle low if we then go ahead
and take a look at bitcoin compared to
gold in the s p 500 yes bitcoin is down
35
over the last year because the base
effect when it was going absolutely
parabolic at the start of 2021 but over
any other time period two three four
five six seven eight nine ten years
bitcoin is absolutely destroyed gold and
the s p 500 worth paying attention to
then if we look around this forty
thousand five hundred dollar level only
315 days out of all of bitcoin's life
has it actually been above this level
that means that for about
93.5 percent of bitcoin's life it's been
lower so if you bought at any point
there and you held till today you would
be in profit
then if we take a look one of my
favorite metrics is the compound annual
growth rate over the last 10 years
bitcoin sitting at 146
over the last decade and that five year
sharp ratio about 1.53 still superior to
all other assets gold s p 500 nasdaq and
tlt
and of course this is all happening with
an incredibly high inflation environment
in the united states 8.5 report coming
in for the month of march significantly
above that two percent target that comes
from the fed and if we take a look will
clemente pointing out that the spread
between the cpi and the 10-year yield is
at an all-time high not exactly what you
want to see if you're a long-term
investor but is it actually eight point
five percent inflation or not well it's
hard to tell there's a brand new metric
out called true flation which points at
thirteen point four percent being the
actual inflation rate we're trying to
measure a more accurate inflation
measure than the 8.5 cpi number so if we
then go ahead and we take a look at on
chain metrics will clemente and block
we're doing a fantastic job this week
going ahead and breaking down what's
going on first short term holder cost
basis we can see here on the far right
that the price ended up getting rejected
off of that short-term holder cost basis
this is usually because people have been
in the market less than 155 days as soon
as they get near break even they've been
under water they're going to go ahead
and they're going to sell that's why we
continue to see struggle to get up above
that short-term cost basis then if we
take a look at the futures open interest
with crypto margined accounts what you
can see is that that continues to trend
downward this means that people aren't
using their bitcoin or cryptocurrencies
to actually grab any sort of margin this
means it's healthier and it's unlikely
that we will see a long long cascade of
any sort of volatility in the market
then if we go ahead and we take a look
at exchange outflows we can see that
it's reached a rate that's only ever
occurred three times before in bitcoin's
history that was in march of 2020
december of 2020 and september of 2021
and so if we then continue one of my
favorite things to look at this week
this is a very very important chart is
the supply not moved in at least one
year we are now at an all-time high this
means that the bitcoin bulls are not
selling
then block where taking a look at the
entity adjusted dormancy flow showing
that in the heavy opportunities though
it's just the sixth time ever that we're
here it's also the longest time bitcoin
has ever spent in this zone and then the
illiquid supply continues to go
absolutely parabolic that pink line
showing that the market continues to get
more and more illiquid very important if
you're going to look at an asset that is
simply determining price based on supply
and demand and lastly talking about
demand think about that persistent bid
in the market coming from the luna
foundation guard that's right the terra
ecosystem saying that they're gonna buy
three billion dollars worth of bitcoin
well they've been doing that here we
have their bitcoin holdings in that
foundation you can see that they
continue to stack thousands and
thousands of bitcoin about a hundred
million dollars or more per day as long
as there's a persistent bid in the
market and we have a more more illiquid
market something tells me that all we're
gonna need is some sort of catalyst and
this thing is gonna go boom i hope that
you enjoy these weekly updates next week
we'll be back with myself and will
clemente going ahead and breaking this
down on video but in the meantime i hope
this is helpful and we'll see you guys
next week hey you did you like this
video great we make five of them a day
and post them here on this channel make
sure you subscribe like the video and
see you next time